hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well fairly early on
in Plato's dialogue the Meno where
Socrates is talking primarily with me no
and also the few other characters who
pop in from point to point there's a
paradox or a dilemma articulated by
Socrates he's saying that Meno himself
is about to fall into it and that they
don't want to fall into it and it's
often called a Meno paradox or sometimes
the Meno dilemma
after the the dialogue after the
character now Plato and Socrates they're
not the first people to actually
articulate this Socrates actually calls
the debaters trick so it's it sit out
there in the Greek culture and its most
likely coming from from some of the
Sophists and it's got an interesting
ingenious structure when we say them
it's of dilemma what we mean is that
it's it's a very brief argument and it
says you can either go this way or you
can go this way you can't pick both and
you can't get out of picking one of them
and you're not going to like either one
so you're screwed no matter what that's
what a dilemma is properly speaking and
if we want to say that it's a paradox on
the other hand what we mean it means
that it goes against or around or
in some way jars with doxa that is you
know common believe common opinion and
so a paradox is something that somebody
says that sounds reasonable but also
makes us say well that can't possibly be
true but I'm not quite sure how to get
out of it
so what's interesting with the Meno
dilemma is three things one is what is
it
you know what's its structure we'll look
at that first and then second what are
the ways that we can actually approach
is what are the ways that we could we
could answer this get out of it refute
it Socrates proposes one there are
several others that we could possibly
look at and then the third thing that I
think is often overlooked in this
dialogue is that Socrates says look if
you buy into this it's actually going to
lead to something bad and not something
bad on the horns of the dilemma but
rather in your attitude in your behavior
so let's look at the first part first
the way the dilemma goes is you can't it
says you can't seek or inquire about
anything and why not
well you can't carry out any sort of
intellectual or even practical
investigation because if you know the
thing that you're actually trying to
figure out trying to seek trying to
inquire about then you already know it
there's there's no need to actually go
looking for it you've already got it's
sort of like saying I'm sitting in my
chair and I want to figure out how to
get to my chair and then somebody says
to me look you're already there or
people do this all the time you know
they they walk around I can't figure out
what I did with my glasses and then
somebody says well you you've got them
on your face sometimes feel actually
wearing them and say I can't find my
glasses I've done that more than once so
that's one award of the dilemma if you
already know it then there's no seeking
and if there's no looking for anything
more you already know it on the other
hand if you don't know it well then you
have no idea how to start you don't know
where to look for it you
what you're looking for so you know you
could go looking in general but you have
no idea whether you're gonna find it or
how to recognize it when you do find it
because you don't know it and if we if
we think about this there's some flaws
here that I think you can you can see
fairly quickly
Socrates interestingly enough now we get
to the second thing that we want to look
at socrates doesn't take the easier way
in saying well maybe you know something
halfway or maybe you have partial
knowledge maybe you know enough about a
topic to actually know where to go look
for it
or what you would you know be looking
for or how to recognize better and worse
knowledge about it and we generally do
that in terms of you know background
knowledge or other other knowledge that
we have you know if you think for
example of going to Wikipedia to gain
more information about something and you
know a lot of people rail on Wikipedia a
bad source it's actually getting quite a
lot better over over time still wouldn't
use it as a primary source for anything
but it's a good place to direct you to
the primary sources that you might
actually get primary you know right up
front dealing with the thing itself
knowledge from so Wikipedia is a
knowledge device or knowledge technology
in a certain way you might actually pose
this this question Wikipedia and say oh
dear Wikipedia how can you possibly know
anything you started out knowing nothing
it's really the case ten years ago and
you know you can't even be sure whether
your your entries are correct whether
your knowledge actually counts as
knowledge and you know Wikipedia is an
approximative process right the peer
review thing there's all sorts of
debates about whether it's really
peer-reviewed or not and you know
there's all sorts of complaints made
about it but let's just go along with
the theory for for a moment
the idea is that you've got some
background knowledge and you can use
that to figure out what you're talking
about to be able to recognize hey this
sounds plausible this is probably gonna
get me to where I want to go so that
would be one way to respond to this
another way that you could respond to it
would be to think in terms of a type of
knowledge that Plato discusses but
always wants to assimilate to something
that we might call discursive or
intellectual knowledge and that's the
knowledge that goes into a craft or art
or skill you know playing an instrument
for example if you want to learn a new
song and you want to know how to play it
that's more than just being able to read
the notes it's not just about how to
translate that into you know physical
behaviors I'm you know pretending I'm
playing a banjo or bass is what I used
to play it's it's about something which
integrates the body integrates the mind
integrates our aesthetic sensibilities
and that can that can admit of degrees
right you can you start out when you
first learn a song you're kind of clunky
with it you make mistakes do you know
the song well you kind of know this song
but not really and now you'd actually
play it a lot and practice it you work
over the rough parts and you can
reliably play it but you you still don't
have you know the sort of feel and
facility that comes with complete
mastery you know the song but do you
know it as fully as you could if the me
no paradox were true then knowing it at
that level would be all there is and and
there'd be nothing more you could gain
but true musicianship particularly when
it comes to interpreting a song means
having a kind of mastery that is also a
type of knowledge and you know it
develops because you do keep on seeking
you do keep it
inquiring into what you already do now
we could say the same thing about about
persons you know the fact that I know my
best friend or know my wife or know my
cousin doesn't mean that I know them
entirely and yet I would still in fact
know where to go to find out information
most information from them and I would
understand how to interpret it in the
process of the inquiry so there's
another way in which the me no paradox
fails what Socrates responds socrates
actually says I've got just the right
the answer for this doctrine of
recollection which we're going to do
another core concept about because it's
it's its own topic before we were born
we actually saw all the things that we
can have knowledge of and when we are
learning about them what we're actually
doing is remembering we already have the
the knowledge of an implicit or innate
or you know some other way along those
lines manner and so we already do know
things we think that we don't know them
but we do know them and as we work
through them they become a little bit
more clear over time and therefore we we
actually should seek what it is that we
want to know about but we need to seek
you might say within if you want to know
what justice is the answer is within us
but it takes a lot of work to bring it
out now the last thing that's very
interesting about this discussion is
Socrates says you really don't want to
buy them you know paradox not just
because you know you know it's not true
gives a more pragmatic approach if we
accept this Meno paradox we're going to
become lazy we're not going to be the
opposite which would be being courageous
or being persevering in our quest for
knowledge
we you know we are able to recognize
there's a lot of things that I don't
know there's a lot of ways in which I my
knowledge could be a lot better a lot
more developed than it than it currently
is I'm not even sure if I know the
things that I know or if it's just true
opinion so the the examined life in
large part consists in trying to further
our knowledge trying to increase our
store of knowledge and if we were to buy
this me no paradox then we'd be sort of
paralyzed we wouldn't actually continue
this quest to learn anything and perhaps
in the process get to know anything